this man i want to stay consistent with
the music you know as long till i'm done
just with that part of my spirit you
know i'm saying that right now um
i really feel like not that i
rediscovered something but it feels like
you have though yeah i mean thank you
kevin that's i didn't want to say for a
minute it felt like you weren't really
like into this [ __ ] anymore yeah i mean
it was a lot of factors you know a
little bit what i touched on earlier
about the business side and just certain
things when things you know it it gets
like um
i don't want to say
not being into it because i was always
into writing songs and making music and
i do it by myself most of the time so
what is it not to be into but
um just rediscovering that passion you
know i'm saying in that initial mission
statement you know what i'm saying and
having great friends and people that you
know and love like here boy that to just
remind you you know i'm saying it and
support you through it and that's an
initially honestly why i thought it from
the west side would love three and why
it was so important to me and just
seeing a you know the
it's only been out like not even two
weeks so just seeing the initial you
know feedback just lets me know like
okay it is a lot on the table for us and
it is a segment of just music in general
and especially rap where it's like the
conversations and the things that i talk
about in the music that i talk about is
necessary you know i'm saying it's a
void and
i feel like it's my job to you know shed
some light on that no you're definitely
i feel like you've been back in your bag
the last couple years man thank you so
it's it's it's been great it's been
great to see um exactly i can't wait to
hear the t-flat [ __ ] yeah nice it's
gonna be crazy it's gonna be dope man
it's gonna be on point like we got we
already got songs i'm excited about like
sharing that's why i feel you know real
good about the music that we're making
and even saying that it and just
honestly just us being it's really about
when
as artists and friends that we all
seeing eye to eye and in a great space
as human beings you know what i'm saying
and that's when i feel like and what
i've seen like you know not saying we
all got to have a great a lot of money
or you know so far it's just you know
just real life and i feel like that's
happening right now and from the west
side with love 3 i feel like it's
definitely one of the reasons why you
know and i want to continue that